so
i'm i'm kate i'm an assistant professor
in the department of geological and
environmental sciences
and i'm what we call a geochemist which
means that i study the chemistry of
earth materials
how fluids and rocks interact it's a
pretty broad area
and so my particular area of expertise
is in what we call reactive transport
and this is thinking about what happens
when fluids are moving and reactions are
happening simultaneously so it's sort of
like chemical engineering
of rocks and minerals and earth
materials so it's a really fun area to
work in i love it and one of the things
that i love about it is that we work
across really broad scales and so
the figure on the left hand side there
is actually a picture of a
basin that contains oil and gas there's
a seismic image of a basin at 100
scale of hundreds of kilometers the
picture in the middle is actually at the
scale of nanometers this is actually a
mineral surface that's been exposed to
co2 and we're trying to understand the
reactions that happen
and then on the far right is a really
interesting example that's about the
size of my fist and i forgot to bring it
i meant to bring it but it's actually a
rock that's been turned entirely into
co2 which is amazing so it's a
mineral called magnesium carbonate and
i'll talk about it in a second
and so we've had a couple of projects
going in the the broad area of carbon
sequestration we had a gcep funded
project which looked at the idea of
mineral carbonation in particular and
this is
reacting co2 with minerals to form
carbonates
we also did a little bit of work in the
course of that project on the
idea of abiotic co2 reduction so turning
co2 back
into different types of hydrocarbons and
finally we looked a little bit at saline
aquifer storage
and different engineering strategies to
help turn the co2
into mineral forms to keep it from
leaking back to the surface
so we've had kind of a broad array of
topics i thought just to
sort of get us going on this idea
we would start off with a little fact
checking um
and so this is a quote it was released
back in may one of my favorites of the
most recent array of wonderful quotes in
the news
but this was from our esteemed
representative david mckinley who was
the head of the house
science committee and this quote came
out right about the time when the
pentagon
when the house decided that they should
forbid the military from thinking about
the effects of climate change
so probably symbolic but it was an
interesting vote and
so his quote here that we're going to
sort of analyze was that climate change
alarmists contend that man-made co2
is the cause of climate change most
people may not realize that 96
of all co2 emissions occur naturally
so just let's take a poll here and see
what you guys think
true false or i have no idea so true
raise your hand move which one true it's
okay your professors aren't here
we have some truths everyone's going
through
we're talking about that it's so big but
um so okay so true fall through i have
no idea
you guys are pretty good you do better
than most audiences do um
so to understand i'm going to trip over
this too i'm just going to move it
so just understand this question a
little bit there's a really interesting
point that emerges
about how the carbon cycle works so this
is just your average
carbon cycle diagram and what's shown
here the blue numbers
are the sizes of the reservoirs and
pedograms of carbon so 10 to the 15
grams of carbon
and the red diet red arrows are showing
the fluxes between the reservoirs so
quickly we can start to get a handle on
whether this
representative was telling the truth
so we have plant respiration and soil
respiration that are
that are returning carbon to the
atmosphere and photosynthesis which is
taking up
co2 and so those two about equal each
other out they sort of cancel out
um in terms of net co2 from the
biosphere then we have volcanoes which
emit a small amount of co2
land use change and fossil fuel burning
so if we add those up we get something
like
what is that seven petagrams of
carbon per year and then we can look
over at the ocean the ocean's also
approximately in equilibrium with
respect to co2 exchange there's a little
bit of an imbalance now that's driven by
the perturbation to atmospheric co2 and
then we have this huge reservoir of the
ocean which receives
some co2 from rivers mainly in the form
of bicarbonate
and then this bicarbonate is transferred
into the sediments and permanently
buried
so that's kind of the breakdown we have
so if we sort of add up the natural
carbon cycle before humans came into the
picture
we can think about the change in carbon
in terms of the net flow
into the atmosphere and the net removal
and if we do that we see that volcanic
emissions are really the only net source
of co2 that we have and that's about 0.1
petagrams of carbon
per year and the only removal sink we
have to get carbon out of
what we call the surface reservoir which
is the ocean and the atmosphere is 0.1
pedograms per year in sediment burial
and so these balance out so we have no
change in carbon
if we add in humans we see that the
fossil fuel burning plus
the land use change is about seven
pedograms of carbon per year
so it turns out that human activity is
roughly a factor of
70 over increase in net carbon to the
atmosphere
over the background state which is an
astronomically big number if you think
about it
we have never seen an abrupt change of
that magnitude in earth's history and
we've seen some pretty abrupt changes
so this is a remarkable one that that is
happening today
so going back to the question of whether
our congressman was telling the truth he
was but he was exploiting the difference
between net and gross flexes and so
96 percent gross is true
um but when you look at what the actual
implications are of that tiny nut that
four percent i don't know who was that
said that um it's really big
so i like to think of this as we're
basically emitting co2 at 70 times the
speed limit
which is probably something like i don't
know what is that five times the speed
of sound or something
so it's a really astronomically high
number um
i will uh are you guys interested in
hearing about how earth has done this
help manage carbon over geologic time
scale as you are okay
i'll say a little bit about it it's a
pretty fun story
um so the idea for earth's moderation of
the carbon cycle was developed by
actually a mining engineer in 1878 and
then it was capitalized
on by yuri in about 1948 and
this reaction is a reaction between
calcium silicates so this is a
rockberry mineral and co2 and the co2 is
either in the atmosphere in the soil
environment
derived from plants and through the
breakdown or dissolution of these
minerals
in the presence of co2 we transfer
alkalinity bicarbonate to the oceans
where we precipitate limestone
and quartz and that permanently removes
co2 from the atmosphere
so why don't we run out of co2 we have
volcanoes we know that are emitting co2
if we actually look at how this process
works it's governed by this sort of
effective rate constant we'll call a k
if we look at how this
works it's actually a stabilizing
negative feedback that keeps
carbon concentrations in check and so we
can write a really simple equation
obviously we use big models to predict
this
today but we can write a simple mass
balance statement that says the change
in carbon
in the ocean atmosphere system is equal
to the production
from volcanoes minus what comes from
silicate weathering
and you see this dependence on climate
that's because when it's warmer you
weather things more quickly
and that removes co2 and keeps the
system in balance so it's a very classic
stabilizing feedback
that is operated over a million year
time scales to keep
atmospheric co2 levels fairly constant
and this is just a plot showing
atmospheric co2 over the last 60 million
years
quite a long time span so we're down
here today
but times for example the eocene period
we had
quite high levels of co2 we don't know
exactly how high because we don't have a
way to measure directly we use proxies
but up to you know possibly as high as 1
000 to 3000
ppm co2 the reason why
we know that this works is shown here
this is a
some modeling that one of my students
just did actually looking at the
long-term carbon cycle balance and what
he's been able to show is that
over a million year time scales despite
large changes in co2
the atmosphere's actually stayed in
balance and that means that this
feedback has been strong enough to
stabilize carbon
the problem with this if you remember
back to the size of these fluxes is it's
very small
and so it only recovers from
perturbations to co2 such as we're
imposing
today over about a hundred thousand year
time scale so it takes
a while to get that carbon out of the
ocean atmosphere system
because of this process so that's kind
of the geologic perspective on what
we're doing today and i'll just mention
there's an interesting period right
here at the eocene paleocene boundary
called
the paleocene eocene thermal maximum and
it was a time
very analogous today when massive
quantities about somewhere between a
thousand and five thousand pedograms of
carbon were released to the atmosphere
warming was about three to five degrees
c and it resulted in
massive ocean acidification and several
major extinctions so it was a really
profound interval that's very analogous
to today
yes sometimes skeptics use this
is that these are unfolding over
millionaire time scales
and if we want to wait a million years
for the perturbation from anthropogenic
co2 to go away then
then it probably will be absorbed and
redistributed
by these natural processes but the rate
of change that we're imposing today is
just so much faster
it's faster than anything we've seen
yeah what led to the
spike in the carbon in like the
like the insecurity even that is
identical to what we have right now
yeah it's debated um i i don't think we
know exactly there's a lot of different
possible causes one of them is
destabilization of methane clathrates
and released a bunch of methane to the
atmosphere
it's a wide range of ideas from volcanic
eruptions
so i don't think the exact causes are
known
temperature extinctions during that
massive explosion
um the problem with it was that there
was so much ocean acidification that we
lost the carbonate record that we would
normally use to reconstruct
what happened so they're working on
developing better reconstructions and
better records for that time period
i think the estimates now are between
three to five degrees c
um and so but it was a a pretty major
event
yeah say curiosity this is like is it
possible that if you have like a few
volcanic eruptions they need to like
change the actions between the things
i mean you have plate boundaries which
control where the volcanoes exist
um you know but if you think about like
the implications of this
70 times um as much co2 emissions you
would have to take a volcanic chain
the size of the cascade mountains which
go through most of oregon washington
and up through um parts of british
columbia and put 70 of those
on the continent so we would have to
turn the whole world into volcanoes
basically
that helps yeah and can you talk a
little bit about ocean acidification
and just like what the effects are
between the atmosphere and
ocean acidification okay
i'm not a marine geochemist there are
much better people like ken caldera who
thinks a lot about this
i'll do my best and if i say anything
wrong someone will have to correct me so
as you know the ocean has a fairly
complicated buffering system we have a
lot of calcium carbonate there so as you
increase
co2 some co2 partitions into the ocean
which reduces the alkalinity and
eventually you hit a point where
you under saturate with respect to
calcium carbonate and so you start
dissolving calcium carbonate
and that's the real concern today over
loss of coral reefs and calcifying
organisms and surface oceans
eventually that's not sustainable and
you'll start to redissolve
existing pre-existing or older calcium
carbonate and you'll probably return the
system but again that's a really slow
process
relative to you know the increase in
acidity that's coming from
the solution of co2 into the ocean is
that yes
that's like is it kind of a similar
process to like a weathering that
happens in limestone buildings due to
yeah sort of like acid brain right like
there's
yeah yeah basically yeah you're
dissolving you're creating conditions in
the ocean where calcifying organisms can
no longer create
a driving force to create their shells
and so their shells actually start to
dissolve or they just can't create new
ones
they're seeing this now in some mollusks
they can't actually create shells
effectively
so um uh yeah it's a similar idea and so
that i mean
the key there is if we could get more
alkalinity into the oceans
that would help yeah i think that the
oceans
are taking up more co2 than anyone
can understand why they are that there's
this this extra reservoir that's
sort of saving us but nobody quite
understands can you
talk about that i i don't know very much
about it okay
yeah i couldn't say anything but does
that mean
um yeah i think there's like
i think there's a couple of issues there
and that one that
the missing co2 sync is
now i think some people are also
thinking it might be on land
is my impression um and
part of the issues with the ocean might
be that we didn't have a good
understanding of temperature
um but i don't know very much about it
that's just it's kind of off the top of
my head from what i've heard okay
so that's the geologic story here
um and so what i've just told you
basically is that the earth has some
ways that are pretty effective at
storing carbon and if you look at this
diagram you can see that if we put it
into the oceans there's a lot of storage
there
the earth's crust is astronomically big
much of that is calcium carbonate that's
been stored and then we have fossil
fuels which are a relatively small
reservoir but we can kind of use these
to tell us where we should put carbon
so one option is to store carbonate
minerals that would be the most stable
form
of co2 in the environment the next would
be to store
co2 as organic carbon and reducing
sediments because
if it's organic carbon such as biomass
from
agricultural activities is unstable in
the soil there's lots of little
organisms that view that carbon as
twinkies and want to oxidize it and eat
it
so we need to put organic carbon in
reducing environments if we want to keep
it there for a long time and then
the third one is probably gas co2 stored
as a gas and subsurface reservoirs and
we have many natural examples in fact
they're mined today for co2
where co2 has been stored in the
equivalent of oil and gas reservoirs for
tens of millions of years and
this idea this isn't the best figure
this is just kind of getting at the
that conceptual idea that so here's co2
with zero enthalpy
and the amount of energy to create any
of these reduced forms of carbon is
roughly about what you would get from
burning it so you don't really gain
anything by turning carbon back into
other forms
and then if you react co2 with minerals
these are a bunch of different minerals
these reactions are actually exothermic
and you end up with a more stable
end product than um going the other
direction
so in terms of what we can do now
technology technology wise
i like to think about our geoengineering
strategies for the subsurface
really in terms of kind of three main
things
so how big how much can we put down
there we've got the seven pedograms of
carbon per year that we have to deal
with that is just a huge
number how long can we keep it there it
doesn't do us a lot of good to put
something
down in the ground and have it come back
up 10 years later
and then you know when when can we do it
is it something we can do today
is it something we have to do 50 years
from now because we just don't have the
technology
and then there's kind of this how much
question and this comes back to your
question
and i would say that you know most of
these strategies that are talking about
large-scale carbon storage in the
subsurface
are you know far off at least are on the
very far right-hand side of the mckinsey
curve which is
to say that we're looking at maybe 60 to
per ton of carbon to sequester it it's
very expensive and i'll talk i'll talk
about some of the reasons for that
um so i'm going to talk about the one we
can do now which we can pump co2 into
the subsurface and we can hold it there
and sometimes we can use it for enhanced
oil recovery and i think it was
someone in this group that mentioned a
ccs just a way to keep us reliant on
fossil fuels
is it you know not necessarily solving
the problem and i want to talk about
that because i think it's a really good
point
and then co2 into minerals so forming
minerals
you can do this either above the ground
or beneath the ground and then there's
this idea of enhanced silicate
weathering and this is basically flying
airplanes around the world and
sprinkling minerals on the earth's
surface
to basically stimulate this natural
weathering process that we talked about
earlier
so um this is sort of arranged in terms
of
how big and when and then the one that
i've been kind of interested in and
we've had some success
is the idea of putting co2 into the
subsurface and using the natural
chemical potential of the subsurface to
turn it back into organic carbon
and it's kind of a crazy sort of pie in
the sky idea but i think it's a really
interesting
thing to think about and um not
necessarily crazy
totally crazy at least um so for those
of you who aren't familiar with how
geologic carbon storage works it really
consists of four
steps and so the first step is the
capture step and so if we're looking at
a
fossil fuel power plant and really ccs
is only
thought to be even mildly
technologically feasible at stationary
fossil fuel plants because you need this
gas stream
to capture the co2 and so capture i know
less about capture there's a woman here
named jan wilcox in energy resources
engineering who does a lot of work on
capture but if you think about what has
to happen you basically need to
um have some sort of sorbent that will
take the co2 out of the gas stream
and then you have to get the co2 off the
sorbent so it takes
heat there's some degradation of the
sorbent over time
so this is where the big energy penalty
comes in and it can be as much as
40 to 60 percent energy penalty on the
plant for co2 capture
so it's a really big number and doe has
been really pushing to bring this down
but it's been one of the big
cost and efficiency barriers
so after we capture the co2 we compress
it into pipelines and we pipe it to the
place where we want to inject it
so we have a significant component of
pipeline transport and when you start to
think about the scale
we're talking about these multiple
pedograms of carbon takes a lot of
pipelines to move them around
but technologically we have experience
with all of these the oil and gas
industry is really good at
piping things they're also really good
at putting things underground and taking
things out of the ground
and so the idea for geological
sequestration is to pump the co2 down
into the subsurface and you can see that
we have these like weird clouds of
co2 on these diagrams and
that's because co2 is in a supercritical
fluid when we pump it underground and
that allows us to get a lot more fluid
underground as opposed to storing it as
a gas
so in terms of how much we have a lot of
storage capacity for
co2 and this is just focused on north
america and i'll show you some maps of
where this is happening
worldwide so we can put oil and gas
we can put co2 into depleted oil and gas
reservoirs we've already taken the oil
and gas out
so in terms of u.s
numbers i think 60 years worth of u.s
supplies is about 140
gigatons of co2 so it's a big it's a big
number it's about 60 years worth of
our current production rate unminable
coal formations are another place that
people talk about
that's about 80 years of storage
capacity for the u.s and then
saline aquifers which are basically very
very deep subsurface aquifers that have
water that is
not at all fit for human consumption
this is water that is
10 to 100 times more saline than sea
water so not something you would ever
drink
but there's a lot of storage capacity
you can see going through especially
parts of canada and
the gulf coast huge amounts of storage
capacity
yeah how would you store co2
in for example an unbindable coal
formation is there
enough like permeability to store
yeah that's a good question the the
thought is yes
um but these are generally lower
porosity permeability rocks
um so yeah that's a good it's a good
point
um you know most of these some of these
are carbonate
a lot of these are carbonate reservoirs
um that have a lot more porosity
yeah is there another okay
so just to have a phase diagram and a
talk about ccs seems important this is
the phase diagram for co2 and this is
pressure
temperature and these are the
temperature gradients for a warm basin
and a cold basin so
you know most of the us would be
somewhere in between here and at the
pressures we're thinking of injecting
here's the critical point for co2 and
most places we're thinking of injecting
or somewhere around in here so
you know 100 to 150 bars and
temperatures between
80 to 100 degrees c so in this case
we're dealing with a
supercritical fluid which is interesting
because it allows the co2
the co2 that phase is more buoyant than
water so it comes up and it nestles
against the top of the reservoir
which means that we need to have some
sort of impermeable layer at the top of
our
aquifer to stop the co2 from migrating
further up
and this is just shown in a very
schematic way
here so here's our what we call a seal
or this
cap rock that's an impermeable unit like
a shale if you guys know about shales
um it's stopping transport here's our
well we're injecting co2 and the blue is
showing the supercritical co2
over time that co2 dissolves into the
water
and as the co2 dissolves into the water
the water becomes more dense and you get
this sort of convective flow
that continues to aid and dissolving the
co2 into the water
so if we look at um what we call the
trapping contribution which is how much
co2 has been
stored or how and how safe that storage
is
since we've injected it initially we're
just relying on the structural and
stratigraphic
trapping so this seal that stops
anything from moving upwards
and over time we get residual trapping
which is co2 that's stuck
in capillaries and then finally the co2
dissolves and then finally
in some places we might start to form
minerals if we have the right rocks yeah
you said co2 is less than instant water
how does if it starts if you dissolve
the co2 that's
why would i become more dense
why would the water become more done
after after
after this was dissolved um yeah because
you're adding
you're adding the co2 to the water as it
dissolves so you're changing the density
slightly so you get these
this sort of convective flow
yes and so you can imagine most of the
subsurface is not composed of a flat
gray rock we have faults
and different things that occur in these
reservoirs we have to know they're there
to keep the co2 down
oops apparently i animated all of the
different features here
get through that and so this is now
getting back to the question of you know
characteristic storage time versus
storage capacity
and there's a lot of lines and things on
this diagram i just want to draw your
attention to a few of them
so here's what i mentioned earlier the
issue with soil carbon is that
you know we could potentially store a
decent amount of it but it doesn't stay
stored for very long
here's underground injection so we have
a huge storage capacity
and we think it'll stay there for maybe
you know tens of thousands of years
which is pretty good um and then we can
go up to this
feature we call mineral carbonates which
has both a massive storage capacity and
a really long characteristic time scale
and i'll say a little bit about
you know what are the technical
challenges with ccs right now
a lot of it relies on physical trapping
so you know we have
some understanding of multi-phase flow
we need a better understanding a lot of
people are working on having better
models to understand how the co2
goes in and reacts with the fluids
geomechanics is a big deal we've had one
co2 injection site shut down because of
induced seismicity
and leakage of the co2 so understanding
how the over pressurization that
comes from injecting co2 changes the
subsurface is another big area of
research
and that ties into reservoir
characterization so they use seismic
imaging to actually detect faults but
seismic doesn't have a very high
resolution and so you can still get
leakage up you know small
faults and things like that um and then
finally if we do have a leakage event
what do we do and it turns out that
it's actually pretty easy to stop co2
leaking you just need to
pressurize from above and you can push
the co2 back down so
so those are some of the challenges the
other challenge on the chemical trapping
side
is that most sedimentary rocks and
waters don't have a lot of
divalent metals and that's what we need
to make the carbonates that permanently
lock up the co2
and the time scales over which minerals
tend to precipitate are pretty slow
relative to the time scales we're
interested in
but i would say overall these are
somewhat i would say they're minimal
problems but they're problems we have a
pretty good handle on
um it's really you know a mature
technology that
i would feel comfortable if someone
wanted to put co2 underground
in california what are the real
challenges
we've talked about this a little bit the
price of co2 capture is still really
high
so right now we're around 60 tons 60 a
ton
doe is hoping to get it down to 40 a ton
that's sort of the goal
long-term site management if you think
about putting a lot of co2 underground
most people would want you to have some
sort of insurance for the next hundred
to a thousand years
that if anything goes wrong there's
going to be somebody there to actually
fix the problem
sort of like yucca mountain when we
wanted to put nuclear waste at yucca
mountain
they wanted the site performance
originally it was supposed to be i think
10 000 years and then it was up to like
100 000 years that they had to be able
to demonstrate that the waste would stay
there and the same thing is sort of
happening with co2 so that's
one of the other issues with cost is
this long-term site management you need
future planning the pipeline transport
requirements
and then really you know this touches on
what you guys were saying there's no
economic
incentive um to undertake such a costly
measure
so that's been the real barrier to
seeing co2 happen and then
there's also been a backlash i think
that some of this comes from what's
happened with fracking
where you know there's an interest in um
what's happening in the subsurface
and then epa rule 111d i don't know if
people are familiar with this
this is the new epa regulation for point
source power plant emissions
and what they've done is say federally
we're going to reduce co2 by this amount
and each of the states has their own
allocation that they have to meet
and they did not include ccs in their
in their estimates at all and so um
that's not
it's not looking overly positive right
now yeah
waste injection oh sorry so deposit
injection
is what the old ccs wells used to be
regulated under and it happens a lot in
the chemical industry
so when they make titanium dioxide for
example they have a lot of iron left
over
so they just find a saline aquifer and
inject the iron underground
and they're done um
i guess if anyone in the us wanted to
build a coal plant they would have to
have sequestration to meet like 111d
yeah they would just not build a coal
plant like there's no future cool
coal will never i don't think there will
ever be another coal plant built in the
us again would be
i guess i don't know for sure but that
would be nice um
so we do have a lot of sites that have
been underway there's a nice
website i think i listed at the end from
co2
crc that lists all of the different
sequestration sites so sleipner in the
north atlantic is taking co2 from a
natural gas
site and just re-injecting it
underground
after a separation plant and that's
partly driven by the carbon taxes
associated with
some of the north atlantic countries
snovet is the other one that's also in
the north atlantic they're doing the
same thing they're just taking the co2
from the natural gas field and
re-injecting it before
combustion wavern is an enhanced oil
recovery
site where they're planning to use the
co2 to get more oil
and insulin was another site in north
africa this is the one that had
induced seismicity and was shut down
because of co2 leakage
and then gorgon is run by chevron it's
off the coast of australia this is the
biggest site to come online
and it's also a natural gas co2
injection site
but you can see there's a wide array a
large fraction of these the eor
sites are all the crosses you can see a
lot of these across the u.s
are enhanced oil recovery sites
so there are some companies doing pretty
innovative things one of the challenges
for enhanced oil recovery is that you
need a constant
stream of co2 and if you think about a
power plant they don't necessarily
generate a constant stream of co2
especially if they go down
so c12 energy is kind of an interesting
company that started in berkeley i heard
they were moving to denver
their idea was to buy up a bunch of poor
space in the midwest
and inject co2 underground from the
power plants and store it there
and then use it sell it to eor operators
and because they could guarantee this
kind of constant stream to eor
they're actually apparently profitable
they're making money off of
ccs which is one of i think the first
companies that's been able to
do that and if you're not familiar with
enhanced oil recovery the idea is that
we only get about 15 10 to 15 of the oil
the first time
we extract it from a reservoir so they
either usually go to tertiary or
secondary recovery with water and then
sometimes they can use co2 and so the
idea is you would
use the co2 to get more oil and then
just leave the co2 down there
ideally
and then this comes back to another
person's question which is
do we need gcs and this is actually a
report from
the recent ipcc working group 5
looking at mitigation strategies and so
this is the baseline this is direct
emissions
of co2 for different sectors so
transport buildings industry
electricity net afolu
is um agricultural forestry and other
land use
and then they ask the question okay well
can we get to 450 ppm
with ccs and the numbers to watch are
actually these numbers these are the
number of models that could come up with
a solution
so could we get to 450 ppm with ccs and
the answer was yes you can see some of
the different strategies so some models
did it with
big changes in electricity some models
did changes in land use
but most of the models could actually
solve the problem
and then when we go to 450 ppm co2
without ccs
look at the numbers only three to five
models could actually even find a
solution to the problem
and so the way that i like to think of
ccs is it's not
a long-term solution but it may be our
only kind of short-term solution that's
big enough to make a difference
okay so i'll say i'm running i guess
close to out of time but i'll say a few
things about these kind of other
possibilities
um oh you go to 5 30. okay
i thought it was 5 15. okay good
so these are some of the other
possibilities mineral carbonation and
the idea here is to take
co2 you could inject it underground or
you could
do this above in the subsurface but the
idea is to rely on the chemical
potential of the rocks to convert the
co2 directly into carbonates instead of
forming it storing it as a fluid and
what's shown here is a cross section
this is actually a cross section through
california so the mountains over here to
your left
have a rock in them called tripetonite
how many people have seen zerpette night
no wind yeah yeah it's actually they use
it a lot
they use it in stanford as a building
stone a lot and it is the california
state rock i should have brought some
it's a bluish greenish beautiful rock it
feels very
like slippery and snaky this is actually
a piece of the earth's mantle that has
been pushed up onto the side of
california and so it formed very much
out of equilibrium with
the earth's surface and it's composed
mainly of magnesium iron and a little
bit of calcium
plus some silicate so these are really
reactive rocks they dissolve very
quickly at the earth's surface
but they've been pushed up in slivers
onto the side of california into the
sides of many other continents
so they're very reactive and then we
have the sedimentary rocks like the
sandstones that contain our petroleum
reservoirs which basically are nominally
not reactive they don't have any um
reactive divalent metal cations and so
the challenge really is that co2
mineralization the rocks that are
reactive have no porosity or
permeability
um the rocks that are less reactive have
lots of space but they have no ability
to
sequester co2 so it's a real trade-off
um and so the reaction we're talking
about
is one between a mineral called olivine
which is a magnesium silicate it's
actually
also known as peridot the green gemstone
and the bottom of this necklace
many of you probably have some um
it's also found in basaltic rock so if
you've ever been to hawaii how many
people have ever been to hawaii
yeah have you been to the olivine beach
on the big island
okay so there's an entire beach made out
of olivine on hawaii that's really
spectacular
um so it's a neat it's a neat rock so
when olivia sees co2 it reacts to form
magnesium carbonate which is a white
carbonate mineral and amorphous silica
this reaction is 95 positive volume
change so it means you basically double
the size of your
products from your starting product
which is not good if you're worried
about porosity can fill a lot of space
and then it doesn't happen very quickly
the kinetics are sort of limiting
and we've been studying a natural
example of this in california this is i
forgot to put a scale in here but
this is about a 10 meter thick vein of
this magnesium carbonate forming in a
rock
and this is a picture of what happens at
the mineral surface so this is the
olivine this is 50 nanometers
this is the silica rich layer basically
this part of the reaction
forming on the surface so it can
passivate the surface
so these are the technical challenges
but if we go back to the question of how
big
and how much i showed you the earlier
diagram that suggests that it's a really
big potential
storage option this is a plot these are
just
dots instead of actual sizes of the
rocks but this is showing the
distribution of these magnesium silicate
rich rocks we call ultramafic rocks
and this is actually our field site
which is 70 miles
east of here on the other side of mount
hamilton and it was the world's largest
magnesium carbonate mine
it's one of the most spectacular
examples the only reason why it wasn't
fully mined was that austria could mine
their magnesite for cheaper
during world war one and world war ii so
they left most of california's magnesium
carbonate
so we've been studying what happens we
see these large magnesium carbonate
veins
these are actually some of our
experimental products where we've been
looking at how fast this happens in the
lab
and this is one of my colleagues
professor gordon brown
and what we call the chamber of secrets
but these are absolutely massive
magnesium carbonate veins that have
formed from co2 reacting with the rock
so mother nature has figured out a way
to make this happen we just haven't been
able to engineer it
yet um and the the big challenge has
been
to make this happen it appears that we
need some mechanism to fracture the
rocks and so if you think about people
were nervous about fracking and co2
sequestration
um this is even more of a challenge
because we have to do hydraulic
fracturing to at least get the fluids in
there initially
so that's the real challenge for mineral
carbonation
people think that once the reactions get
started because there's a positive
volume change they'll keep
kind of creating poor space down there
it'll be sort of a self-sustaining
system
the economic benefit to these mineral
carbonation projects is that
effectively you could walk away when you
think about the long-term storage of a
thousand years
you might not need to ensure that for
these kinds of sites because the co2 is
all converted into a rock so
there's a trade-off there so the places
where people are doing this with actual
co2 from power plants
the main place is actually iceland where
they're taking co2 from geothermal
production and injecting it back
underground
there's been another pilot study in
washington
those are probably the two main places
australia is doing a similar version of
this
with above ground with mine waste
so not as much going on with basalt or
mineral carbonation as with geologic
storage but it's one option
and then there's some kind of crazy
things you can do with minerals this was
in the new york times
um a couple of days ago did anyone see
this you saw it yeah
um you saw it yeah so so this is the
same mineral olivine here they've put it
on a playground and the idea is that
this mineral will just sort of take up
all the you know co2 converted into
bicarbonate or make a
magnesium carbonate mineral in the
playground um
and the the the people working on this
have
have you know some interesting ideas
about sprinkling olivine around
um the i see
so in fact there's amused by that idea
um there have been some studies actually
some studies published in prestigious
journals that have shown that
for example taking olivine and dumping
it in the tropics you could change river
alkalinity enough to actually influence
seawater chemistry in a positive way so
it's not completely out there but
the cost of mining and everything else
um is a challenge
anything terrible about the morphology
like asbestosis like
you know oh life ratios and things yeah
so
these minerals are tend to be associated
ultramafic rocks turn into serpentine
and serpentine contains asbestos
minerals in fact you were all drinking
asbestos minerals a little tiny bit
because our drinking water
comes from crystal springs reservoir
which is actually in serpentine rocks
and so they filter the water
before it comes to us the good news is
is that the kind of asbestos that forms
in these deposits is not very harmful
it's not carcinogenic
like the other kinds of asbestos so
there is a little bit associated with
olivine typically
the other mineral that's often
associated with olivine is chromite
which is the main mineral that contains
chromium and obviously chromium's a
toxic carcinogen when it's oxidized
so there are some possible environmental
downsides of
you know of these rocks but presumably
you could separate out the magnetite
and chromite fairly easily and so
there's a little bit of nickel and iron
in them but that's probably good for
plants anyway so
i don't think anyone has done a very
good estimate or analysis of the
potential
toxic aspects of olivine
um so i just mentioned this the idea
that we could sprinkle olivine around
um and then the other part of this is a
slightly more realistic endeavor which
is that instead of putting the co2
underground and worrying about poor
space we just
bring the minerals to the surface and
react them with the co2 above ground
and actually a group here at stanford
and energy resources engineering
department did a full life cycle
analysis
of mineral carbonation it's a really
nice
job that they did and all this is very
busy i just want to walk you through the
the things they included so extraction
which is the mining part of it
the transport the processing you have to
crush up the minerals to make it very
fine grain so it has surface area
to react quickly enough and then the
chemical conversion
which is the reaction with the co2 and
then any processing
that you need and then the
transportation and either reuse or
disposal
and just to kind of remind you of what
the challenge is for this
um this is a plot of the concentration
of magnesium
and ph and so if we think of a water
with co2 in it
we're basically at this ph range where
magnesium
two in solution is favored and you
basically have to add alkalinity to form
the magnesium carbonate mineral and so
the company that you guys looked at um
new sky cholera that's been everyone's
challenge for doing this to make
products that contain calcium carbonate
is that you have to add alkalinity and
getting that source of alkalinity is
challenging
so these guys did a full analysis
of the carbon dioxide emissions
associated with each step
in the process and the big one
here is the chemical conversion and that
i believe is all associated with the
capture
and what they did if i remember
correctly is they tried to
scale everything by a thousand tons per
day of co2 which is what they thought
they needed to
make a difference and
so finally they looked at a bunch of
different strategies so the idea here is
we could use olivine or we could use
waste slag from
metal refining we could use
coal fly ash which also has a lot of
reactive components so we could use a
number of different waste streams
and convert it into carbonates and on
the whole the olivine which is shown
right here is the most
um favorable in terms of if this is for
um a thousand times sequestered this is
the loss
from the industrial process
oh yeah this is a really key assumption
that they they needed to estimate
how much alkalinity was produced or how
much
sand and gravel so a is how much
alkalinity is produced in the u.s
total b is based on how much sand and
gravel we produce so it's the difference
between like 20 i might have written it
down
20 megatons 18 megatons per year
in a and 760 megatons per year in be
so there's some pretty big assumptions
in here the other one
is um isn't actually in the extraction
it's a big you know mining is an
expensive costly effort so
um but there are some companies doing
this so clean sky was one calera is
another one who i believe
brett constance who was the founder came
um last year and
they've probably fighted
yeah it was a neat workflow they're a
neat company um they've
they've been developing calcium
carbonate products to make cement so i
believe if i remember correctly the
sidewalk
at the corner of sand hill and foothill
is made of their cement from their
process
and they've also been making different
tiles and
pottery and benches out of calcium
carbonate so they have a
unique process for making products out
of calcium carbonate
and their trick for getting the
alkalinity
is to use an electrochemical process
that
generates both a precursor to
pvc and sodium hydroxide and so that's
how they get the base
to make the calcium carbonate and
actually that technique has turned out
to be more beneficial than
this approach so they've kind of focused
more i think on the electrochemical side
of their business than the co2
product side so i'll say one last
word about sort of the crazy idea what
are the crazy things we could do
if we had the technology and this is the
idea of sort of subsurface cycling of
co2 or basically converting co2 into
a reduced form and storing it in reduced
environments
and the idea is that if we put co2 down
into these petroleum reservoirs we know
that they're
reducing because the petroleum has been
there for
millions of years so if we can make the
co2 into something that's more reducing
it should stay there and then maybe we
could actually get
beneficial products in terms of either
stimulating subsurface microbial
communities
or making actual useful products
and this is a pretty complicated diagram
i'm just going to explain the basics so
this is the log of
aqueous hydrogen and this is basically
just a proxy for redox conditions
um so if you guys are chemists you can
think of eh
or reducing conditions so
in this plot very oxidizing conditions
are down here so the earth's surface is
somewhere in here
and then this is just temperature and if
we look at petroleum reservoirs they
plot
up here so they're quite reducing
and these black lines show the mineral
reactions that actually control the
redox conditions in these reservoirs
and the red lines show the ratio of co2
to acetic acid in these reservoirs and
we're just using acetic acid as a proxy
for
reduced organic carbon and so the idea
is that
co2 would come down and it would attach
to a mineral surface
and the mineral surface would either
catalyze or at least promote the
reduction of co2 to
another organic molecule in this case we
made formate
so we've been able to get this to happen
in the lab we haven't been able to
do it in the subsurface but the idea is
that if this is where petroleum
reservoirs sit
and you add co2 you basically come down
this direction and there's now a
chemical potential that would drive you
back up
to these initial conditions and convert
the co2 back
so there's a lot of you know redox
conditions redox potential down there to
help us it's really the technological
side of the catalysis of the co2 and
there's groups here that are doing
electrochemical co2 reduction and we
might be able to learn
from some of their materials and
actually facilitate
a review yeah yeah they use really
things that are really similar to
natural minerals um
okay so that's just kind of an overview
um i put up some different reading
so if you're interested in more about
the co2 sequestration sally benson
who's here at stanford has a nice review
paper in the journal elements
jen wilcox wrote an amazing book on
carbon capture she's also here
and then klaus lachner has been thinking
a lot about the mineral carbonation side
and been very
vocal that that is in his opinion i
think one of our only
real viable strategies but the new ipcc
working group
report is worth taking a look at
and then some of the co2 capture project
websites
are listed here i think that's it
yes yes yeah
thank you so much sure yeah
questions yes research being undertaken
on trying to find ways to sequester some
of the other harmful
um emissions from fossil fuels like
methane and
socks and knocks and mercury and stuff
like that
yeah um that's a great question a lot i
mean a lot has already been done on the
socks
side um and
you know in some of these cases people
have looked at co-injection
of h2s with the co2
the real issue there there's not so much
a problem once it goes underground the
issue there seems to be more with the
pipelines and the pumping apparatus
so one of the sites i mentioned in
iceland is actually co-inject
co-injecting h2s
and co2 because the geothermal wells
produce a lot of h2s
as far as what to do with
the h2s byproduct i think cleans clear
sky we keep forgetting their name
is is capitalizing on on that um
mercury people have been looking at it
it's more of an issue with coal i think
um but people have been looking at
develop better methods to scrub
mercury from coal and actually general
cox
that's one of her specialties is looking
at mercury
so does that okay yeah
can you capture methane you
could i suppose i don't know that anyone
is
is that is concerned with methane
gets released from permafrost yeah
there's some interesting spoons
well then you're just producing co2
which is not as spoken of greenhouse
gases methane
oh yeah yeah i mean i think that the
natural sources i agree are a big
problem i don't know how much
how much the industrial emission of
methane is it seems too valuable why
would you want to let it go
or did you at least burn it off i think
um
you know with all of these gases they're
hard to soar
you know that's one of the challenges
with any of them is the sorbent part
yeah being used to
sort of um examine the the cost of the
attorney continues like determining
um like their appropriate pressure to
put
the senior doing because like like for
instance you are giving an instance of
like you know dco2 coming back up like
what like led to that was like
the that cost did something weird that
they didn't expect what would happen
yeah so that's a great question i didn't
show any model simulations
um the oil and gas industry and actually
even people here at stanford there's
been
decades worth of work on what they call
reservoir simulation which is
simulating how fluids move and how the
pressure changes and they're very
advanced
simulation tools they're constrained by
seismic measurements at the site usually
i believe what happened at insula was
that there there was a sort of low
permeability unit
that they didn't know had a low
permeability
and the pressure started building up and
instead of just stopping the injection
they kept going
and i believe that was what caused the
problem
but there is substantial modeling being
done and we've been doing a lot of
modeling on the effects of leakage and
the idea of putting reactive barriers
down that would react with the co2 and
stop it from
moving up any further so sally benson
over an ere is one person who's worked a
lot on that and there's a whole group
over there that it's really impressive
you know the knowledge and the
computational ability that they have to
solve these problems
thank you again this was so sure this is
terrific i appreciate it
yeah it was fun